Hey guys, it's Justine and today
We are chatting about all things Apple watch
Series 3 now the biggest difference between the new series 3 Apple watch is that it will now support
Cellular and what that means is you're basically not going to need your phone
You will just need your watch to do all the things that you would need your phone for like make calls for instance
Text messages you can even listen to streaming music which is something that I'm really excited about
Another thing that is new is Siri will actually talk back to you previously you would just get a response via text
But now because of the new processor that is in the Apple watch series 3 Siri will be able to respond to  you you won't
Even need to look at your phone you do watch your tiny phone on your arm
So cosmetically the old watch and the new series 3 is the exact same size
The only difference is the back heart rate sensor crystal is and I quote
"two pieces of paper thicker now I didn't get a chance to try it on and it did not feel any different at all I
Did not even notice that this was bigger
I feel like two pieces of paper is extremely thin
And I think about all the new things they have packed into the new watch that's a pretty big
Advancement something that I thought was pretty cool is the biggest question was well
Where's the antenna going to be if it's still gonna be the same form factor the entire front face of the screen is the antenna
And these little green dots
demonstrated right here
But my new friend that I met at the Apple event that shows you that it is connected to cellular
They share this amazing
inspirational and a very
Emotional video during the keynote that showed all of these people who have used the Apple watch for the past year in the past two
Years, and how it's changed their life there isn't even an instance where the Apple watch actually saved the wearer's life
They realized that their heart rate was much higher than it should have been for a resting heart rate when you're not doing any activity
And that can sometimes signify something is wrong so with that that allow this person to be alerted instantly that hey
I think I should probably go to the hospital so obviously you heart rate is a very important thing to have being monitored constantly
It also plays a huge factor in fitness and what I love about the new Apple watch is they're going to be working together with
A gym kit to allow you to sync your watch data
And your gym equipment together so for example if you're running on a treadmill that treadmill is gonna be able to more accurate release
How long you've been running your distance your pace all of those things and a lot of times especially of gym equipment
It's very hard for those things to be tracked by wearable devices
Because it doesn't really know what you're doing you might be able to tell it yeah. I want to treadmill yeah
I'm on a stair step
But it doesn't actually know the machine itself has the data of what tasks you just performed so now all you have to do to
Be able to get that data right to your watch is
Tap and go they also said that they're going to be having some support for snowboarders
I've never snowboarded before so I'm not really sure all of the things that are gonna be going
Into that and what you guys would be looking for we'll be able to monitor elevation
And I'm sure maybe there's sort of a setting in there that they could be like hey
How fast was I going down this mountain?
I'm not sure, but I feel like that information would be kind of interesting to me if I was snowboarding
I'm also not a big swimmer, but there are some new features for swimmers
They also did a really cool demonstration of this woman on a paddleboard in Tahoe
And they made a call to her and the only thing that she was using in that live keynote was her watch and it sounded
Really really good brand, and I don't make many phone calls
But there's a lot of times when I take my dog for a walk that I like to still have my phone then I'm holding
My phone walking the dog. I'll have a water, and then I have to pick up the dogs
There's a lot of things so if I'm just taking the dog for a simple walk
I will now just be able to take my watch and still be connected
Still be able to get my text messages my apps and other sort of
Notifications that I normally wouldn't be able to get if I didn't have my phone with me
I'm a huge fan of being able to stream music from your watch. That's gonna. Be really cool, so using Apple music
They said that you'll be able to stream more than 40 million songs you think about that and put that in perspective
That's all that's a lot of music. This is one of the new watch faces
It's a nice gold and it kind of matches the new iPhone eight gold color
And it looks really really good in person this watch band is called
Spicy orange. It's so great. This is one of the new sport loop bands that they just introduced as well
And it's a new type of model that it's made of like this breathable fabric so when you feel it
It kind of feels like velcro, but like a really soft velcro. It's kind of spongy. It has a little bit of push back
I'm not really sure how to explain it and velcro is right here
So this allows you to pull it as tight as you can all the way around your wrist now
I have a problem though because I have small wrists
Which I probably should pop down to the 38 because it would make a lot more sense
But I do like having a bigger screen
I'm basic
But I usually don't run into this issue of the watch bands being too big because most of the sport bands they come with two
Different sizes they come with a small/medium and a medium/large band
So you're able to adjust that to the size of your wrist and I was at the Apple campus
And I was so excited that I was like I am gonna treat myself
And I'm gonna buy this Hermes Apple watch band and one that I thought I was getting was this loop band
But this loop band is only made for the 38 the 42 comes in the one that I was unboxing and I didn't know this
At the time so when I opened it
I was a little bit surprised because I was expecting that it was going to be the loop and
all the way around
A little deceived by the display so unfortunately when I tried it on I was like man. This is really really big
Problem with getting the 42 millimeters I
Put it on the tightest setting and everything and I wore it for a little bit
I was like I have to return those if there's no way that I could justify spending this much money for an Apple watch bands
It does not even fit so my suggestion to you guys if you are planning to get one of the more expensive watch bands do
Try them on first go to the Apple store
Give it a shot because I don't want you to have the same problem that I had while we're on the topic of watch bands
They also introduced a bunch of new colors of watch bands. I love being able to switch up my watch bands
I could care less about what I'm wearing
I care way more about what my watch band is but since I've been wearing this Nike sport loop one. It's been my favorite
It's a very breathable. It still does get a little bit sweaty, but it's way better than the ones without the holes
That's why I'm really excited about the sport loop because that is something that I feel it will absorb sweat
And you'll have to worry about being like hmm another day
I gotta loosen up my Apple watch because my arm is sweating in addition to the new gold face
They also have this gray ceramic. I'm a huge fan of the ceramic watch basis
I have the white one which I'm sure many of you guys have watched me unbox here previously
I love the ceramic it feels great on my wrist
It is a little bit heavier than the aluminum, and it is a little bit more expensive
So we're deciding which Apple watch is right for you
I think what it really comes down to is price
And do I want something a little bit smaller and lighter, and is it necessary to have LTE
I don't think it's a how to present necessary to have LTE especially if this is your first album watch
But this is your first Apple watch
I think it's gonna be a really cool feature to have to really not have your phone if you work in a job or for
Say a class you will be able to have access to pretty much everything that you would have on your phone on your wrist
Let's take a look at some of the new watch bands that they introduced this one. Here is my favorite
It is so beautiful. It is called the fuchsia. It's a beautiful leather fuchsia of it
I feel like I'm probably gonna have that same issue that I have with this that I had with that Hermes version then you
Sport loop here are some of the new colors. This flash looks awesome here. It is spicy orange
I love it electric pink midnight blue dark all of sports seashells sport. I feel that will probably get dirty
I've never had any problems with any of these white bands getting dirty because they are that silicone so it's very easy to clean but
What this I feel like it's more of a fabric so I mean I would probably just throw it in the wash when I'm doing
Laundry. I don't know what will happen to it
I can probably do it test to see the outcome so maybe I'll get the white get it dirty
See if I can clean it and see what happened so I can do a test for you guys to see if it's okay to
Throw your Apple watch loop fans in the wash people also
Tell you that you're not supposed to throw like tennis shoes in the watch, but all of my Nikes
I throw them in like every other week and guess what they're fine. Here are some of the new sport bands
We have a rose red book blue sport band the ultra violet dark olive
Soft white I like this fog sport fan. That's a really good color pink midnight blue black
It's still a really huge fan of the Nike sports fans, so here's a few other new colors
They have the pure platinum and the black pretty sure they had this one before but I still really liked that look this one looks
To be like a dark blue. Here's a few of the woven nylon these all look really great as well
There's really so many customizations that it's insane. Here's in the leather. Here's the cosmos blue
There's my baby pink fuchsia other colors. These all look really good than modern buckle
I'm more of the sporty fan, and here's their Mezen leather
They're so, beautiful, but here's the problem 38 millimeter only I did not know and they all look great
No real question is how much of these things gonna cost so we're gonna look here
And this is the breakdown of all of the models they have
You can get it with GPS or the GPS and cellular. We've got this series three
This is the silver aluminum with the Fox for fans
That's a really nice look like that looks super slick course the rose gold is by far one of my favorite colors ever although
I'm probably going to be getting the ceramic one again so to differentiate between the Apple watch seriously the cellular and the previous versions without
Cellular they decided to put a red dot on the crown, I'm gonna be completely honest with you
I do not like the red dot at all red is my least favorite color
I think red is a really great accent color, but in this sort of a scenario
I don't think it is it all mostly because there are so many different colors of Apple watch bands and different
Combinations and some of those things as a designer myself
I would never put red with some of these colors like it's just like it's like a contrasting color
And it's just I am NOT a fan at all, but with that being said I'm still gonna get one anyway
I do think that it was smart on their part to put something cosmetic that would differentiate the two
But I feel like the red is there nothing else that you could've come up with like there's gotta be
Something something else that you could have done beside the red either way. Here's that lineup. Here's the silver aluminum case with the GPS
They've also got the rose gold the Space Gray
Space Gray aluminum, it's a gold look at that, and it looks incredible
They also have some of the Nike watch series so here. They are here. Here's the silver aluminum case with pure black
Oh my gosh the Space Gray the silver aluminum Space Gray and looma do with OGS you get the point
and then we have the Hermes Apple watch series these ones are super expensive because of
Obviously the brand and the leather bands
then we have the Apple watch edition so that brings us here to the white ceramic and B gray ceramic and these both start at
$12.99 I pick areas to see what that number?
Combination is of the Apple watch faces and the fans and the GPS and the cellular like how many different combinations
Can you make with all of these cuz it's gotta be pretty high another thing that I thought was really cool
Is they announced this air power so it's kind of like a power?
Wireless connecting match you can put all of your devices onto it
And it will charge them at night
At night because I feel like that's most of the time that you're going to be using that when I'm on the go or during
The day I usually have like a movi charger with me
And I don't usually charge my Apple watch on the go one of the things that I forgot to mention is all of the watches
That were at the Apple event we're running watch OS 4
And there's a lot of new features in watch OS 4, which makes it pretty exciting
I never did install the beta on my watch
I thought about it
But I think I'll just wait at this point for the actual thing to come out if you guys can't tell I'm a huge Apple
Watch fan I wear mine almost every day everywhere. I go. I love dressing it up and dressing it down
I have worn it so many times on red carpets usually sometimes
It's you know with an outfit that you should wear an Apple watch with but I will wear it and a lot of people ask
Me what do I use my Apple watch for?
mostly
And it's weird because I don't really know if there's one set thing that I use it mostly for I feel like it integrates seamlessly
Into my life, it's sort of second nature. I just kind of look at it
I see what my schedule is I go do set activity
I love being able to use it for navigation when I'm driving in my car
It kind of gives you that little hey the gentle tap of you have to turn soon
Which is great because I'm not very good with directions
It's also great for when I'm in a city and walking
I can just have those walking directions on my wrist
And I don't have to have my phone up so if you've ever been skeptical about the Apple watch
I think now is the time they have worked out all of the bugs all of the kinks
And they have finally figured out the place for this thing anyway
This was a very long video, and I talked a lot, and I probably could keep talking
But I'm gonna end it here and as soon as I get my hands on one of the Apple watches
I will make a video about it, and I'll let you guys know my full review and all of my thoughts but just for now
I'm gonna go ahead at this video now. I'll see you later. I can't believe I still edit my own videos what am I thinking?
I'd have a lot more free time to play destiny if I didn't edit
Did I like it?